ça va on dirait un hôtel Ibis et puis le
surveillant est beaucoup plus doux parce
que l'ambiance est beaucoup plus douce
les mots grossiers les plus importants
c'est oh jute alors il y a pas de mots
vulgaire que tu vas en détention c'est
waouh tu as peur on a aucun problème on
était dans un quartier où comme je l'ai
dit il y avait des gens qui avaient une
certaine éducation et on était entre
gens bien éduqués ceux qui ne voyait
c'était ceux de l'étage uniquement et
qui tous les jours me disait bonjour
vous allez bien ça va la santé il savait
que j'étais pas bien parfois passer un
petit mot sous le sous la porte courage
mais bon etc alors ce qu'il dit alors
Thierry toi surveillance qui a des
traitements de faveur pour les VIP bien
sûr bien sûr c'est quoi par rapport aux
autres détenus
en plus c'est
bah tiens appelle-moi le directeur ben
le directeur il vient de suite le
directeur prend un café avec le détenu
il parle et son entretien ça dure ça
dure des heures et des heures et puis
avec les autres du du tout pas du tout
du tout du tout ils ont vraiment accès
au téléphone ou pas tous les détours que
c'est un téléphone
ils ont pas de après ce qui se passe
c'est souvent l'avocat a le droit de
rentrer avec son téléphone l'avocat peut
passer son téléphone et le détenu on l'a
peut appeler enfin surtout les VIP il
peut appeler ce qu'ils veulent c'est
quoi les autres avantages qui peuvent
avoir les VIP
des promenades en plus ils ont accès au
sport de suite par exemple des soins
médicaux bah c'est c'est c'est c'est ça
quoi et en fait ils sont ils sont plus
tranquilles ils ont une détention
sont bien David
toi comment ça se passe pour les
prisonniers en quartiers VIP
[Musique]
j'étais en détention normale et c'est
vrai qu'on entendait parler voilà déjà
quand j'étais incarcéré on entendait
parler des quartiers VIP et voilà on
disait on entendait c'est l'hôtel là-bas
ils sont comme à l'hôtel et tout ça et
tout mais ce soir je voudrais pas
acheter la pierre quand même au sur le
ministère de la Suisse ou la détention
ou la pénitentiaire parce que en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que pourquoi
c'est l'hôtel pour eux c'est parce que
il y a moins de moins de passage il y a
moins de monde donc les cellules restent
propres et les cellules qui sont rénovés
restent propres et alors qu'en détention
normale et bien c'est des anciennes
cellules et on se retrouve à deux à
trois à quatre en cellule même des fois
5 et donc quand on a un Kishi l'autre
Qui qui crie à la fenêtre qui fait sa
bouffe dans le milieu de la cellule
enfin voilà qui c'est à trois quatre
dans une cible la cellule on n'a pas non
plus des cils comme ça ça c'est des
nouvelles cellules rénovées toutes
récentes mais quand tu vas à Fresnes à
Caen dans les anciennes tôles du 18
siècle et que les cellules sont toutes
pourries bien sûr que tu te poses des
questions tu dis pourquoi nous on n'a
pas le droit à ce traitement mais les
choses sont en train de changer je les
ils sont en train de faire des nouvelles
voilà ils rénove les anciennes prisons
ils ont construisent des nouvelles
prisons et donc ça change c'est dur et
donc là par exemple là j'étais à la
prison de Strasbourg là encore
aujourd'hui je sors je sors du train en
atelier j'étais avec toutes les détenus
ils entendent parler je voudrais dire
Cyril je passe un message je suis en
train de faire la tourner toutes les
prisons tous les détenus me demande de
te passer un message ils disent merci
Cyril de parler de tout ça vraiment être
merci tous et il me dit ils disent les
choses sont en train de bouger et voilà
il pousse un grand coup de gueule parce
qu'ils entendent ils voient les ils sont
en train de voir les photos des des
cellules VIP et eux ils vivent à deux à
trois à quatre dans des cellules voilà
Raymond n'est pas fou quand quelqu'un
Raymond dit oui c'est l'hôtel et que
tout le monde tout le monde n'est pas au
même tout le monde n'est pas au même
prix quoi enfin tout le monde n'est pas
pareil donc au même niveau voilà Thierry
qui est surveillant sur sur certaines
prisons oui c'est l'hôtel là
la prison de la Santé a été renouvelé
rénovée pardon et c'est un petit hôtel
Formule 1
VIP
après ils ont des activités tous les
détenus ont tous les mêmes activités
mais ils sont sur les attentes VIP n'est
pas sur les attentes c'est il a le
biotech biotech si demain un jour je le
souhaite pas mais si demain je suis en
prison je ne serai jamais dans ma
cellule juste pour manger et juste pour
dormir parce que j'ai accès à tout je
peux faire de l'anglais je peux
apprendre le bac je peux je peux tout
faire j'ai même des sophrologues qui
viennent des coach sportifs il y a même
des stars de la box qui viennent aussi
alors on dit que Pierre Palmade voilà il
va être en si il est en prison il va en
quartier VIP c'est pour le protéger des
autres détenus c'est c'est surtout pour
ça en fait oui c'est surtout pour ça
parce que c'est bah c'est pour éviter
comme hier madame Benali a dit c'est
pour éviter aussi qu'il se fasse
racketter harceler c'est pour qu'il
fasse une détention comme tout le monde
mais
protéger et si je peux me permettre en
fait
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que moi je
passe un gros message c'est les choses
sont en train de bouger mais c'est lent
c'est lent même si voilà il faut des
moyens et tout ça et il faut faire vite
quand même parce que ce qui se passe
dans les prisons pour ceux qui sont en
détention normale franchement c'est très
très grave je voilà il y en a ils se
pendent il y en a il y a des suicides
c'est les les l'incarcération est très
très dur on a un gros message pour les
victimes bien sûr là on est en train
d'amener la justice restaurative de plus
en plus un agissant on amène des
victimes avec nous et on débat avec les
détenus les victimes montrent ce que
c'est qu'être une victime il faut il
faut le dire c'est vraiment un truc très
important il y a un gros et ce qui se
passe en ce moment vous verrez vous
allez en entendre de plus en plus parler
rappelez-vous de ce mot la justice
restaurative on a un gros retard par
rapport au Canada et et la France en
train de s'y mettre on amène nous avec
ça et ce que je voudrais dire pourquoi
c'est c'est énorme je peux vous donner
juste une un petit exemple de ce que
font les détenus pour essayer d'être
seul pour essayer d'avoir un tout petit
peu de ce qui se passe chez les VIP je
donne un exemple par exemple
en fait ils sont obligés de gruger
d'inventer des trucs moi j'ai un mec là
il me il m'a raconté une histoire de fou
il a été voir le psychiatre ils étaient
à 4 dans la cellule il voulait à tout
prix être tout seul il a été voir le
psychiatre il a dit psychiatre il a joué
un rôle il était normal il était super
bien il est arrivé comme ça c'est le
psychiatre monsieur je me fais pipi
dessus je fais la nuit je fais pipi je
suis obligé de me changer et devant mes
détenus je suis obligé de me changer et
ils voient mes fesses alors ils veulent
me taper parce que ils veulent ils
veulent pas que je monte mes fesses pour
me laver dans la cellule et tout ça donc
le psychiatre il a fait un mot pour
qu'il soit tout seul en cellule et donc
il a été obligé de jouer un rôle tout le
long de sa peine pour faire style que il
fait pipi sur lui tout ça pour rester
seul ensuite il a été se mettre dans un
rôle de complètement fou alors que le
mec est complètement normal donc il se
passe plein de choses comme ça et c'est
un mec exemple sur tout ce qui se passe
sur ce que les détenus font pourraient
essayer d'être seul donc les choses
bougent mais ça voilà Thierry je vais
rebondir ce que ce que vous dites
effectivement mais il faut pas oublier
que c'est la prison oui nous on les a
pas mis là c'est des gens moi tous les
jours me surveillant c'est dur oui mais
moi j'étais pas Milan en fait je t'ai
pas dit d'aller tuer ça ou arracher les
sacs que tu viens on les dévoiler violer
quelqu'un c'est un délire il faut
assumer ce qu'on fait si on roule à 110
et on renverse quelqu'un mais après il y
a tout il y a tout ce qu'il y a derrière
voilà et justement si je devais cet
exemple c'est pas pour les plaindre
c'est pour dire que ils veulent essayer
d'être seul comme les VIP en fait pour
que tout le monde la détention soit
tourne pour toi pour pour tout le monde
pareil je donne juste un autre sujet là
mon David
VIP sur palmat toi je sais que tu
comprends pas qu'ils sont celui de Baby
moi je comprends même pas qu'il y a des
cellules non moi je comprends pas qu'il
y a des Happy à partir normalement en
France de ce que je alors après pareil
je suis peut-être encore fou de ce que
je sais moi tu ne vas pas en prison
comme ça il faut un fait grave pour
aller en prison d'abord tu vas au
tribunal si tu as rien fait avant bah on
te met du sursis tu ne vas pas il y a
des gens ils ont fait 5 6 affaires
devant tribunal ils sont toujours pas en
prison quand il va c'est que ça fait
grave le monsieur l'a rappelé qui va
c'est que c'est grave quand même quand
il va donc après une fois que tu es
là-bas c'est l'égalité pour tout le
monde ce qui a fait Pierre Palmade pour
moi c'est très grave parce que ça fait
34 ans que c'est comme ça 34 ans qui
passe à travers les gouttes à un moment
donné il lui faut une leçon comme un
autre citoyen comme un autre citoyen
lambda il faut une leçon donc voilà la
prison elle sert à ça et moi quand je
vois des mecs qui font de la muscul qui
sont dans comme ils disent une pièce de
Formule 1 pendant qu'il y en a qui sont
4 5 dans la même cellule c'est pas
normal pourquoi il y en a qui sont 4 5
dans la même cellule et pourquoi on
devra protéger d'autres voilà maintenant
si Pierre Palma ils vont prison et qui
se fait racketter c'est un peu chiant
parce que c'est pas c'est pas un
pédophile c'est pas un violeur d'enfant
j'ai aussi des degrés de compassion tu
vois je suis pas totalement débile mais
je me dis que voilà un moment donné faut
expliquer aux gens quand tu fais des
conneries comme elle a dit Monsieur
derrière il va falloir assumer c'est pas
eux qui les ont mis en prison ils ont
été tout seul c'est le choix de leur vie
ils ont eu leur vie ils ont eu leur
chance maintenant si tu vas en prison tu
vas pas pour rien c'est ce que je peux
raconter Patrick Balkany sur les
quartiers VIP regardez
parfois ce sont les surveillants qui
donnent des conseils à certains détenus
médiatiques peu au fait de la vie
carcérale
c'est la promenade le premier jour et
puis là dessus
les les gardiens ils m'ont dit Monsieur
Balkany
n'allez pas dans la cour sinon vous
allez être
photographié ils vont ils vont envoyer
ça mais ils ont des des smartphones
par jour et qui a quelqu'un de connu
pour fille le photographie et ils
envoient ça par les matchs etc on sait
pas de spécialement agréable pour la
pour la famille de vous voir dans une
cour de prison
en fait c'est faux ce qu'il dit parce
que
enfin ça dépend la configuration de la
prison mais chaque chaque bâtiment a sa
propre
à son propre
sac à court de promenade donc ça veut
dire que tous les détenus lambda vont
dans une dans une cour de prison les VIP
vont dans une autre prison enfin dans
une dans une autre promenade donc déjà
il se croise pas il y a aucun détenu qui
croise les VIP ça c'est c'est
intervention qui donne la gamelle ce qui
les auxiliaires et tous les autres
on a peur du suicide des VIP certaines
cellules sont d'ailleurs spécialement
conçues pour éviter tous les risques
regardez
tout ce qui est mobilier est fixé donc
il ne peut pas le démonter à la fenêtre
et ne pas de poignée donc il peut pas
l'ouvrir il y a une caméra aussi pour le
surveiller et pareil la télé aussi bien
une box en plastique pour la protéger
comité qui l'utilise alors il y a une
cigarette justement où la personne
détenue peut poser justement ce
cigarettes dans la boule ici et s'allume
la cigarette voilà ça évite justement
d'utiliser une flamme le détenu doit
aussi porter des vêtements spéciaux
qui sont facilement déstabilis donc il
ne pourras pas se pendre avec et si les
vêtements il y a pas de lacets de succès
ou quoi que ce soit
ça c'est ça c'est tous les détenus voilà
c'est ça
s'il y a des gens qui sont faibles ou
qui veulent se suicider déjà il y a une
surveillance particulière
on consacre deux ou trois personnels
pénitentiaires qui font des rôles qui
rondes toutes les toutes les demi-heur
ou voir toutes les heures qui note sur
un cahier aujourd'hui il a fait pipi
aujourd'hui il a bien mangé aujourd'hui
il a pas parlé il a pas demandé son
avocat et on note et on note et on fait
on a un cahier des charges on a des si
je peux me permettre spécifique
j'aurais rebondir sur ce que disait
Raymond avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour toi et bon euh je je comprends
quand tu dis que tout le monde pareil et
que tu es le combien d'élite tu vas en
prison mais je pense que malheureusement
on arrive dans on est dans une période
où tout le monde pense comme ça alors
que parce que il y a eu trop de choses
de fait ces derniers siège ces dernières
années l'abolition de la peine de mort
là-bas ouais comme autant du ban quand
le bagne avait été aboli tout ça c'est
un sujet tellement très difficile à
expliquer et et très long à expliquer
donc en quelques mots je voudrais te le
dire j'ai vraiment du respect pour toi
je comprends tout ce que tu dis vraiment
moi je voudrais pas qu'on croit que non
non sincèrement je voudrais pas qu'on
croit que je fais la police du crime ou
que faut pas les mettre en prison tout
ça je je travaille dans toutes les
prisons de France je suis en train de
tourner dans toutes les prisons de
France on a pas je répète cette histoire
de justice restaurative il faut il faut
passer vraiment aux alternatives à la
prison la prison doit doit être pour ce
vraiment les individus dangereux et tout
ça et et toi Pierre Palma il doit aller
en prison pas pour toi sincèrement je
vais je vais pas je vais peut-être
choquer mais si lui il va pas il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres qui vont pas
qui doivent pas y aller d'accord et donc
je serai pour pour qu'il n'y aille pas
si les beaucoup d'autres n'y vont pas
aussi d'accord est-ce que je veux dire